[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avoir des enfants
j'espère que vous êtes aussi sage que
les neveux nounours or vous avez vu
patrons ceux qui sont gentils espiens de
vue ah oui ce sont des hors sont
exemplaires je t'avouerai même que je
suis très étonné de nours moi aussi pas
trop je descend vite les embrasser ce
cher petit monde à cheval
[Musique]
coucou mon petit oscar
allons ferry fier
aucun gros chagrin la non ne pleure plus
voilà temps en temps bonsoir mais que se
passe tu as car un gros chagrin nous il
a peut-être fin non ils ont bien son
troisième but gros lot l'eau c'est
peut-être sa maman qui m'a mais oui ce
sens le petit amour allons console toi
nous allons téléphoné à maman et nous
irons bientôt la voir à temps numéro
raimu faut
nous allons téléphoné à ma mort à
sa salle vas-y à reno
allô
allô allô
qui est à l'appareil c'est moi nounours
c'est toi et millions bonsoir chers
frères
comment vos mes petits très bien emilia
alors très bien
ils sont un peu inquiets car ils n'ont
pas eu de tes nouvelles j'ai été fort
occupés j'ai refait les peintures oh tu
acheté une voiture j'ai refait les
peintures au tu as fait des constitue au
lard effet les peintures on entend très
mal je te passe les petits
ou
totaux j'espère que tu es sage comme une
image emilia ta maman tu embrasses mon
petit rémy vous me manquez vous savez
l'enfant chéri revient vite il va
bientôt revenir vous voir madame emilia
bon chemin la gamme emilia bonsoir
nicolas bonsoir un problème le coût de
biens et millions
aux carmes petit poulet en nounours
choléra mendy demain emilia bonsoir je
t'embrasse
bonsoir je vous embrasse tous
[Musique]
bonsoir madame et médias ont soir
moins cher soit
quelques heures d'or
mais où sont ils tous passer ma parole
ils sont couchés
[Musique]
bonne nuit
trop tentant bonne nuit maisons font là
j'éteins la lune
7pour
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons en route nounours il est tard tu
es trop bavard au téléphone aux
marcheurs venus là je tente chose lui
dit tu n'es lui dira demain bonne nuit
les enfants allez vite vous couchez
embrasser bien fort vos parents et fuck
de boer
[Musique]
on